I have finished my first round of eyebrows and come down with the modia finishing antibiotics tonight and developed a fever today. Oh, she I'm sorry about that.
And that is the problem. I mean, the negative thing about keyboard therapy, you know, the positive thing is it can kill your your cancer, but the negative is that it can kill your immune system.
And that's why if you're going to do keyboard therapy, it's so important that you, you know, you do as much right feet as possible and that you may even have to. So everybody reacts differently to keyboard therapy.
Some people sail through it pretty well. Some people it just beats the immune system to daylight.
Partly it has to do with your genetic detoxification pathway.
Typically you're your side of chrome piece 54 and your on one pathways that detoxify these key modes.
You have defects of those pathways. You don't detoxify them very fast.
And it just stays in your system and beats the daylights out of you. And it's beating the daylights out of the more highly metabolic cell lines. And that is your immune system.
And then you end up with secondary infections like this. And that's not good.
So you may be one of those people that need to bump up your immune stimulants.
Even more when you're doing the chemo, which what are the immune stimulants are typically what we're having one for the cancer typically it's going to be.
I don't have your file in front of you. You're taking a severe stimulus, but it could be the view to could be a mushroom complex that could be even taking more green story that time will help because that's going to give you.
A better of you.
Just by that, doing that alone.